كان هجوما غير عادي لكتائب القسام هو كذلك
لان مقاتلي القسام لا يزالون يتمركزون
لليوم الثالث على التوالي في مستوطنات
اسرائيليه خارج حدود القطاع يتركز القتال
حتى ساعه اعداد التقرير في عده مستوطنات
في المناطق الشماليه والشرقيه والشماليه
الشرقيه شمالا يصل مقاتلو القسام الى زيكي
على بعد اقل من ثه كيلومترات من بيت لاهيه
في زيكي مستوطنه ومعسكر ومحطه توليد
كهرباء للمنطقه الجنوبيه من اسرائيل هناك
يتحصن مقاتلو القسام وقد دخلوها من البحر
الاهم الان ان الكتائب الفلسطينيه لا تزال
تمد مقاتليها بالعتاد والسلاح بل وبرجال
في دخول جديد خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه كان مقاتلو القسام قد دخلوا كل
المواقع العسكريه الاسرائيليه في مستوطنات
شمال القطاع وقتلوا الجنود فيها هذا يعني
ان مساحه تقرب من 70 كيلو مترا مربعا شمال
القطاع فقط كانت خارج سيطره اسرائيل
لساعات ولا تزال مناطق هناك خارج السيطره
حتى الان نحو الشرق سديروت احدى اكبر
المستوطنات في غلاف غزه يقصفها القسام ب
90 صاروخا اسنادا لمقاتلي النخبه في
القسام العاملين في سديروت وفق تعبير
الكتائب هناك يبدو ان مقاتلي القسام
يتحصنون في منازل المستوطنين وبنايات
المستوطنه المختلفه جنوبا من سديروت شرط
من قطاع غزه عشرات المستوطنات والمعسكرات
لم يعلن القسام حتى الان عن وضعيه القتال
فيها لكن الصفارات الانذار انطلقت في مجمع
مستوطنات اشكول جنوبا اكثر من مره وقالت
الكتائب انها قصفت موقع فج العسكري شرق
غزه وصل مقاتلو القسام الى تلك المستوطنات
وتحصنوا فيها الثابت حتى الان ان مساحه
تتجاوز
650 كيلومترا مربعا تضم عشرات المستوطنات
والاف المستوطنين لا تزال مسرح عمليات
قتاليه من المسافه الصفر بين الجيش
الاسرائيلي ومقاتلي القسام لليوم الرابع
على التوالي في معركه طوفان
الاقصى